c'est sur cette base américaine de
Rammstein à l'ouest de l'Allemagne que
le secrétaire américain à la Défense
compte donné une nouvelle impulsion à
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine peu avant
son arrivée Loyd Austin avait annoncé
une nouvelle enveloppe de 2 milliards et
demi de dollars à Kiev comprenant 59
Bradley des blindés légers
l'un des éléments les plus importants ce
sont les chars des chars occidentaux
modernes dont nous négocions la
livraison avec nos partenaires
désormais nous attendons une décision
d'une capitale européenne qui activera
la chaîne de coopération sur les chars
celle qui est visée c'est berlans qui
refusent toujours d'envoyer ces charllés
au parent Ukraine l'Allemagne est
également sous la pression de pays comme
la Finlande et la Pologne qui se disent
prête à en envoyer mais pour cela elles
ont besoin de l'aval de Berlin mais je
vous dis Mesdames et Messieurs que je
suis un peu sceptique et pessimiste
parce que les Allemands se défendent
contre cela comme le diable se protège
contre l'eau bénite
ils ne veulent pas envoyer leur
équipement moderne surtout ses léopards
l'Allemagne assure qu'elle donnera son
feu vert seulement si les États-Unis
livrent leur chats Abrahams ce que
Washington ne semble pas disposer à
faire de son côté Londres a déjà promis
14 chars challenger 2 alors que la
France hésite à envoyer c'est le Clair
Kiev dit aussi avoir besoin de missiles
d'une portée de plus de 100 km pour
pouvoir frapper la chaîne logistique rue
mais la Russie a prévenu la livraison
d'armes de plus longue portée serait
pour elle un nouveau palier dans le
conflit